we have an update for you on a six-month
cbs news investigation into a military
base
that was used by u.s service members
after 9 11.
we've shown you how veterans suffered
serious illness after they were exposed
to toxic materials at the base it's in
uzbekistan it's known as k2
in one of his last acts as
commander-in-chief president trump
signed an executive order
that enables aid for those very veterans
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge is at the pentagon
for us this morning catherine good
morning to you what does this mean
well tony the executive order does not
link kate to an illness but it does
recognize k2 vets are sick
and should be considered for the same
programs as those who served in iraq and
afghanistan
after years of being dismissed it is a
significant step forward
it was disbelief because it was already
a moon shot
k2 veteran mark jackson says response is
poured in on this facebook page
after an executive order was signed by
president trump
during his final hours in office
hundreds of the members had logged in
and written all sorts of things about
how thankful they were
and after years of resistance k2 vets
reported
the v.a was reaching out to them we even
had a few people
put screen shots of emails they had
gotten from the va
that week jackson is one of at least
2500 vets
who self-report illness including rare
cancers
they believe are linked to a former
soviet air base in uzbekistan
known as k2 after 9 11
u.s forces launched classified missions
from the base into neighboring
afghanistan
we were the first responders to 9 11 so
we got sick
first the investigation documented k2
was a dumping ground
used chemical weapons equipment soil
saturated with jet fuel
radiation and chemical agent warning
signs dotted the base
what does the executive order get the k2
veterans
the executive order demands that the va
and the dod
follow their own rules respect
uzbekistan
as a combat support area jackson told us
it opens the door to previously denied
services
every veteran of uzbekistan can now go
into the va and receive the same care
as someone in afghanistan the executive
order ultimately is a first step
towards this direct link between k2
service
and illness yes everywhere is decay
when we first met jackson he shared his
deployment journal
a raw and unsettling account of his 10
months at k2
every yellow tab is a day where i felt
sick jackson's thyroid stopped
functioning
two years after he left the base and
during the course of our investigation
he received a preliminary cancer
diagnosis
an all too familiar story for k2
veterans
our team profiled former air force
mechanic doug wilson
who spent three months at k2 he can no
longer work or drive
after a rare cancer caused brain damage
wilson's plight
caught the attention of lawmakers mr
wilson rides a mile and a half
in a mechanical wheelchair twice a week
to attend his physical therapy
appointments
in december after seeing wilson's story
then acting defense secretary chris
miller
who as a special forces commander passed
through k2
drafted the executive order let's err on
the side of the veteran
and not get caught up in bureaucracy and
endless studies like we've done in the
past
now the defense department has just one
year to conduct
a rigorous study into the health
consequences of k2
this isn't a 5 10 15 year survey
they have 365 days to reduce results
that is a huge step forward says former
army intelligence analyst elba barr
who blames her reproductive health
issues on toxic exposure at the base
disbelief and then just validation
of a decade's worth of issues k2 vets
are now looking to the biden
administration to finish the job
i would ask the president himself help
us you can fix this
you can get us the presumption of
service connection and get these sick
and dying veterans help that they need
and the families of those who have
already died
the help that they deserve a
spokesperson for defense secretary lloyd
austin tells cbs news he is aware of the
k2 health issues
and he will consult with the va about
the most appropriate way forward adding
the secretary believe strongly in our
nation's obligation
to care for veterans and their families
vlad
such an important story catherine glad
you're staying on top of it thank you
very much